So now that we know how to
find the block offset and
the block number,
let's talk about the cache tags,
which is how we determine which block
do we actually have in the cache.
So our cache can contain
some number of lines.
In this case, we have a four-line cache.
We could have something for example,
64 bytes of data in each line.
Let's say that any block from memory can
be placed in any of these four lines.
In that case, when we are given
the address by the processor,
the least significant bits
of the address will tell us
where in the line we
are after we find the line.
But each of these lines in the cache
could contain any block
number from the memory.
So the question is,
how do we find whether our access
is actually a cache tag or not?
And the answer is, in addition to
the data of the blocks, the cache
also keeps a so-called tag that tells
it which block does it have here?
In this particular cache,
the tag will contain the block number
that the cache has in
each of these slots.
So we need four tags because there
could be four blocks in this cache.
So given the address, we take the block
number part of the address and
compare it to each of the tags
we have in our cache.
If one of these says one, that means
that the tag matches the block number
and that means that our data is in
the corresponding line in the cache.
Let's say that this is the situation
we have, so we have a tag match here.
That means that we have a hit and
that our data is here in the cache.
Now we can use the block offset to tell
us where in that line our data is and
we take the data and
supply it to the processor.
In this particular cache, we have
the offset part of the address here,
and the block number is, in this case,
called the tag part of the address.
When we have a cache miss, we will bring
the data here and we will put the block
number in the corresponding tag so
that we can find this block later.
We will see later that sometimes
the tag part of the address
is not exactly the same as the block
number, but in this cache it is.